so we are here today with Professor Alan
Catania Alan is a physician he's also a
lawyer and a professor at Harvard
Medical School when I first went into
medicine you know most of us who go into
medicine we go in it to make patients
feel better we realized that we don't
necessarily always do that because
mistakes happen right in front of us
this is something that's very
preventable sometimes in our control
there's no reason for most of the
mistakes that happen to happen and we
need to do a better job of it because
patients also trust us when they come in
to the hospital I think many of us think
that when we go to hospitals there are
safe places where we go to recover and
where we go to get better
they shouldn't be places where we go and
get hurt I think that I have a job that
has a great mix of work I went into
medicine simply because I knew that I
would enjoy taking care of patients I
added a law degree to my education
because I wanted to move into policy
work later in life I wouldn't see
lawyers of the problem in the system I'd
say the system is the problem in the
United States for every dollar that we
spend on liability insurance only about
40 cents makes it to a patient and I
think we can do better than that lawyers
can help the system improve by helping
patients navigate the system when
patients have been wrongfully injured
and they can't get access to
compensation they can help hold the
right systems and right providers
accountable they can also help patients
negotiate a quicker resolution or a
quicker settlement earlier when it's
more merited so they can really help us
deliver that accountability signal that
we want delivered because patients on
their own may not know how to navigate
the system Tzipi lawyers can really help
with that peace
[Music]